climate change is an unprecedented
global problem the emerging carbon
finance market with a potential for
enormous profits will play a critical
role in helping to solve this problem in
a major advance toward understanding
this new sector the Center for business
and the environment at Yale has
published carbon finance environmental
market solutions to climate change Brian
Garcia Brad gentry and Eric Roberts
developed and edited this important
report Brad Gentry director of the
Center for Business and the environment
at Yale well I think in terms of the way
I think about carbon finance it really
includes two concepts one of them is we
have the problem of climate change
because there's been no price on carbon
anybody burning coal anybody burning oil
anybody burning jet fuel or gasoline has
been putting carbon into the atmosphere
and not paying any price for it so one
part of carbon finance is monetizing the
cost of carbon to the extent that it's
causing pollution damage how do we
assign a price to that and one way to do
that is by limiting the amount of
emissions by putting a cap on the
emissions so if you put a cap on
emissions than different people who are
using fuels and many people need to
continue to use fuels we'll have to do
something to reduce them sometimes you
can buy more efficient engines sometimes
you can drive less whatever and then one
of the ways you can meet your cap is in
essence to pay other people to reduce
their emissions and take credit for the
reductions in their emissions that
wouldn't have happened before and if
you're going to for example pay somebody
else to build a wind farm pay someone
else to capture methane from farms pay
someone else to destroy industrial gases
from their plant you need to have a
system of financing those projects with
financing the construction of the wind
turbines the construction of the
digesters the construction of the
generators and so you bring those two
concepts together into carbon finance
you're putting a price on carbon you're
creating a commodity that's tradable and
you're creating a system that needs
finance in order to create the offsets
that can help people meet their
regulatory obligations to reduce their
emissions government carbon restrictions
and binding international agreements are
necessary components to a functioning
carbon market there's definitely a role
for government in creating carbon
markets we know that through science
that climate change is a human induced
phenomenon in that we have to achieve
certain reductions of the emissions of
greenhouse gases and to the extent
government can establish the goal in the
targets based on science of where we
need to be it effectively through
regulation will establish targets that
we have to achieve now once those
targets are achieved and they're set in
law then it's up to the market to figure
out ways of achieving those targets now
there's always an ongoing role for
government to monitor and make sure that
the market is operating correctly as it
was intended as it was structured
there's always a role for government to
make sure that the projects that
investors are investing in receiving
carbon value from are in fact delivering
the results that we expect of them
they're actually leading to a reduction
of greenhouse gas emissions so there's
always an ongoing role for government in
the carbon markets cap-and-trade has
become the industrial world standard
tool for addressing global warming the
government puts a cap on greenhouse gas
emissions and issues permits to
companies for the right to release
carbon dioxide so cap-and-trade system
is a system established by government
with the intent of reducing the level of
greenhouse gas emissions over time now
that cap is established with a base year
and the government wants to achieve over
a number of years a certain reduction
reduction of co2 emissions to achieve a
goal what typically happens is here in
the Northeast we have the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative that's
established a captain
trade market the first market of its
kind here in the US in fact several
weeks back weeks ago the first trades in
the market occurred and we have a price
on carbon of three dollars now
effectively what that means is if I'm a
company that falls underneath this cat
and I am emitting above what I should be
emitting that I'm now going to have to
pay a price for those emissions and it
happens to be three dollars per metric
ton of co2 now if I'm a company
operating underneath that value then I
have the ability to sell back into the
system and earn some revenue so
cap-and-trade system is a government
instituted standard or a requirement for
the market to achieve a certain
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions
cap and trade systems don't exist
without government the best role for
government in a cap-and-trade system is
setting a cap enforcing the cap and
reducing the cap over time so that you
actually get the incentives to reduce
more completely over time it then is
important for the government to make
sure that there are there's information
available around the market for the
allowances and the market for the
trading that takes place across
facilities under the cap and for helping
to ensure that there are sufficient
market structures so that the costs of
trading are not too high the joint
degree program offered by the Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies and the yale school of
management is preparing students to
become leaders of the new low-carbon
economy I think now is the great time to
be at the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies the school is over
a hundred years old so it has this
tremendous legacy of trying to
understand and apply scientific
management principles to the planet to
forest systems in particular to but lots
of other things we have had a joint
degree program with the school of
management for over 27 years where
students have come in and said we see an
intersection between business techniques
business resources and trying to solve
environmental problems and we want to
explore those under Rick Levin the
president of Yale University in the last
years we've seen a renaissance at the
Yale in thinking about how to be a
sustainable institution not only reduce
our emissions of greenhouse gases but
also how to have more sustainable
sourcing of food how to have more
sustainable uses of water and things
like that and that creates just a
tremendous laboratory for learning on
campus so you have students not only
studying from textbooks but having
students engaging with helping make Yale
a more sustainable place and having
students engage with the network that
Yale has externally not only of a lungs
but of leaders and we're all about
solving the problems that matter how do
we get students and faculty engaged in
understanding the underlying issues the
pressing environmental issues in
preparing environmental leaders to then
go out into society and help us to solve
the problems that matter so we've
actually had a long-standing history of
a joint business environment degree
program here at Yale the Center for
business in the environment is a part of
the new vision of accelerating Yale's
role in preparing business leaders to
solve environmental problems to obtain a
copy of carbon finance environmental
market solutions to climate change visit
yale edu slash CBE y / carbon finance
2008 for more information about the Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies visit environment yale edu
you